madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal à epinal le verdict pour
l'exemple quinze ans de réclusion pour
la mère et la tante du petit génie des
peines plus lourdes que le réquisitoire
l'offensive des troupes russes en
tchétchénie de violents combats dans des
villages du nord-est de cette république
du caucase une opération militaire avec
la poursuite des bombardements au japon
après l'accident nucléaire la levée des
dernières mesures de confinement y
compris dans le périmètre de sécurité ou
iv 80 personnes qui rentrent chez elles
sous surveillance la coupe du monde de
rugby un bon départ pour les tricolores
qui ont battu à baiji cet après-midi le
canada 33 à 20 sous le regard de jacques
chirac michel legrand vient
d'enregistrer un nouvel album à londres
quand le jazz est là l'artiste renoue
avec sa patient un homme inclassable
tour à tour compositeur chef d'orchestre
pianiste et le talent toujours dans la
qualité de ce samedi le verdict de la
cour d'assises des vosges dans ce procès
qui aura indiscutablement marqué la
semaine qui s'achève
des peines qui vont au delà du
réquisitoire de l'avocat général 15 ans
de prison pour la mère et la tante de
l'enfant les parents tortionnaires du
petit génie désormais nous ne pourrons
pu nuire puisque les magistrats ont
décidé après le verdict de retirer
l'autorité parentale permettant ainsi à
l'enfant d'être adoptée valérie ermite
champions passeur un murmure dans la
salle mais aucune réaction de la part
des accusés après six heures de délibéré
le jury vient de condamner sandra la
mère de johnny à 15 ans de réclusion
criminelle
15 ans également pour la tante 12 ans
pour la cousine huit ans pour le père
les peines sont lourdes plus lourde que
celle qu'avait réclamé l'avocat général
les avocats de la défense sont un peu
amers pendant toute une journée
il avait tenté de faire comprendre
l'irrationnel l'origine de la sauvagerie
d'une famille une famille à la dérive
sans repère un plan hors norme où le
passé de chacun n'est que violence et
souffrance il ya dorment déception
énorme
m
on peut se demander de l'opportunité de
plaider je suis donc déçu évidemment je
trouve que la sanction est lourde mais
les sévices endurés par johnny hante les
esprits
johnny l'enfant miraculé diront les
psychologues johnny qui a frôlé la mort
les actes et c'est inqualifiable actes
de torture et de barbarie
c'était des actes très lourd qui ont
pesé très lourd dans le coeur et dans le
corps de johnny à partir de là haut
après quatre jours de débats les jurés
en ont tiré les conséquences sandra
l'enfant battu l'enfant viol est devenu
la mer tortionnaires vient également de
perdre tous ses droits parentaux le
retrait de l'autorité parentale implique
ipso facto le fait que l'enfant devient
pupille de l'état et donc il me devient
adoptables nous feront vraiment le
maximum pour keane et une famille qu'il
soit adopté et qu'il soit élevé par les
parents qui le roi d'octets qu'il soit
élevé dans sa famille ce à quoi tout on
a droit johnny doit maintenant se
reconstruire réapprendre à vivre avec sa
douleur et de nouveaux parents la fin de
l' enquête du tueur en série présumé de
l'est parisien glisse georges qui est
soupçonné d'avoir assassiné cette jeune
femme
les familles des victimes se sont
rassemblés aujourd'hui pour la première
fois au palais de justice de paris un
geste inhabituel ce procès pour avoir
lieu avant la fin de l'année prochaine
joël bruandet christian euros elles ne
s'étaient jamais rencontrés avant ce
matin visages fermés les familles des
sept victimes du tueur de l'est parisien
sont venus pour écouter le juge t-il
leur notifier officiellement la fin de
l'instruction
une réunion douloureuse pourtant les
familles ont apprécié ce geste de la
justice et après deux ans du décès de ma
fille c'est vrai comme mais c'était
quand même une bonne chose
d'avoir quand même quelques explications
après plusieurs mois de psychose dans lé
quartier de la bastille et de république
guy georges est finalement arrêté en
mars 98 il est déjà passé à plusieurs
reprises entre les mains de la police
sans pour autant être inquiété l'homme
décrit par les experts comme un
dangereux psychopathe reconnaît
aujourd'hui avoir violé et assassiné
cette jeune femme parmi elles magali si
rôti 19 ans et hélène fring king 27 ans
selon des analyses génétiques
le tueur en série serait également
impliqué dans quatre autres affaires de
viol et de tentative d'assassinât
autant d'éléments que le juge t-il à
tenter d'éclaircir ce matin
il a associé les familles des victimes à
la compréhension de ce que fait le
système judiciaire dans une situation
comme celle-là il a expliqué les
difficultés de son enquête les éléments
qu'il a pu recueillir pour avoir des
preuves et au bout du compte les proches
qu'il a obtenu essentiellement par le
système du fichier génétique sur le
magistrat
cette démarche saluée par les avocats
n'avaient pourtant rien d'exceptionnel
ce sens l'instruction est donc close et
les familles devront attendre la fin de
l'an 2000 pour assister au procès de guy
georges au japon après l'accident
nucléaire qui continue de susciter
colère et indignation
les autorités ont levé les dernières
mesures de confinement permettant
d'acier aux familles exclues du dernier
périmètre de sécurité de rentrer chez
elle un retour sous sécurité comme ont
pu le constater nos envoyés spéciaux
isabelle bechler et tristan le braz le
moindre plan d'oignons a été auscultée
par des techniciens venus en renfort de
tout le japon et il en fut ainsi de tout
le rayon des 350 mètres autour de l'
usine de retraitement
car jusqu'à ce soir les 83 habitants de
la zone était encore soient confinés
chez eux soit évacué à la salle des
fêtes de la commune jusqu'à la niche des
chiens tout est passé au compteur geiger
pour avoir la certitude que les environs
seront à nouveau habitables qu'il n'y a
pas de résidus de radioactivité dans
l'atmosphère ou sur les bâtiments
je suis vraiment mécontent parce qu'on a
été prévenue à 12h glané deux heures
après l'accident qui nous tiennent
vraiment pas pourquoi on a mis tout ce
temps à nous prévenir et dennis k
sur le parking désert du supermarché
voisin
les techniciens font le point de mesure
qu'ils ont relevés à 350 mètres du site
de la fuite nucléaire pas d'inquiétude à
l'endroit où nous sommes
ça ne dépasse pas la normale 0,06 et
puis on s'accroche seule usine plus les
valeurs augmente
nous sommes en train de faire cette
enquête faut que les gens puissent
rentrer chez eux tranquillement à l'
usine les manoeuvres de réparations
continues dans la plus grande discrétion
voilà désormais 24 heures que l'accident
est maîtrisée officiellement la réaction
en chaîne serait bel et bien interrompu
les riverains de l'usiné n'en sont pas
moins toujours installé à la salle
polyvalente où les examens médicaux les
concernant semble absolument
interminable jusqu'au moment où
finalement en début de soirée les
autorités municipales annonce que chacun
va pouvoir rentrer chez soi famille par
famille maison par maison les valeurs
radioactives vont être re vérifier ce
soir en présence des habitants vers 22
heures ou minuit heure locale les
riverains des usines devraient pouvoir
rentrer chez eux rassurés parmi les
enseignements de cette catastrophe
nucléaire la nécessité d'informer la
population sur les dangers potentiels
en france on reconnaît volontiers que le
risque zéro n'existe pas mais à
gravelines par exemple où se dresse
l'une des grandes centrales nucléaires
les autorités en sensibiliser les
habitants à travers différentes
campagnes à new moore cch dominique maes
posée au beau milieu des dunes la
centrale nucléaire de gravelines la plus
puissante en europe depuis 20 ans elle
fait partie du paysage
et pourtant à quelques kilomètres de là
dans ce petit village on a bien du mal à
l'oublier c'est vrai ça fait peur on les
voit tous les jours
6 à 8 pour décontaminer tout de suite on
n'a pas le temps de prendre la voiture
de fuir depuis longtemps les pouvoirs
publics tentent d'informer la population
sur les risques chez lui eric a toujours
sa boîte de comprimés diodes distribué à
tous les habitants à vannes et en cas
d'accident nucléaire
nour expliqué bon les mesures à prendre
en cas dallaire c'est à dire bon se
fermer les volets ne plus sortir se
confiner dans sa maison même les enfants
sont prévenus des risques dangereux tu
crois ben ça n'est pas si bastien il
faut à problèmes et se fait d'un joueur
et qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire alors si
un problème dont on prend des pastilles
dans la petite école aussi tout est
prévu la salle de jeu deviendrait pièces
de confinement conte qu'elle ferait les
portes fenêtres les fenêtres cette porte
on aurait un point d'eau donc un point
d'eau dans les toilettes et on a le
téléphone
il y a trois ans une simulation
d'accident nucléaire a même eu lieu pour
tester l'efficacité des secours ont ils
ont passé un message comme et personne
me dit de rentrer ce jour là
résultats mitigés sentiment souvent
répandue qu'en cas d'accident il sera de
toute façon trop tard
pourtant pour les autorités il est
important de sensibiliser la population
le risque zéro n'existe pas il serait
tout à fait irresponsable de dire nous
nous occupons de tout n'ayez aucune
crainte
tout va bien au contraire être
responsable c'est être capable très
tranquillement de regarder en quoi
consiste le risque et puis surtout de
regarder quelles sont les mesures qui
permettent de réduire en cas d'accident
les conséquences
responsabiliser et à lhassa blement
répéter les mêmes consignes une nouvelle
campagne d'information doit débuter la
semaine prochaine
cette alerte est la salmonelle dont nous
faisions état dans notre journal de 20h
hier 14 tonnes de steaks hachés surgelés
ont été contaminées c'est l'entreprise
elle-même qui a contacté la préfecture
de la haute-marne pour que soit retiré
ou plus vite ces produits de la marque
royal steak sur place nabila taboury
valérie lucas des steaks surgelés il en
sort très 250 tonnes par semaine de
cette entreprise de congélation de saint
dié
mais il ya cinq jours lors d'un auto
contrôles effectués sur l'un des lots
des germes de salmonelles ont été
découvertes
la contamination concerné 14 tonnes de
viande présent dans le tube digestif
humain et animal
les germes de la salmonelle peuvent
également se retrouver dans les
excréments le manque d'hygiène favorise
ensuite l'infection le keeper du jeunes
chevaux se nomme sushi permanent tant du
personnel que vins locaux donc
si on avait régulièrement des problèmes
on saurait c'est peut-être justement
parce qu'on n'a pas souvent que cela
nous a échappé l'alerté lancée dès hier
a permis de récupérer 11 des 14 tonnes
de steaks compagnie les 3 tonnes
restantes ont déjà été vendus par des
grandes surfaces du nord-est de la
france
denis boîte de la marque royal steaks
dont la date de fabrication et le 31
août 1999 et la date de péremption le 31
août 2000 c'est grave il forcément vu
passer de la salmonelle donc vain c'est
comme les yeux c'est comme autre chose
on retire on croit pas en pros pas de
risques a hérité au consommateur en cas
de consommation les risques gastro
intestinaux sont surtout importants pour
les enfants et les personnes âgées
les premiers symptômes fièvre
vomissements et diarrhées apparaissent
entre vite et 48 heures après
l'absorption de l'aliment
il n'y a pas de problème si la denrée
est cuite
par contre si le steak haché subissait
une décongélation à température ambiante
dans des conditions qui n'étaient pas
très près normal il peut y avoir une
multiplication de ce germe la qui
pourrait entraîner un risque pour le
consommateur
à partir de lundi un numéro vert le 0
800 600 4,012 sera mis en place pour
informer les consommateurs
cette pollution de la marne responsable
de la mort de nombreux poissons des
militaires sont sur place pour procéder
au nettoyage rejoints par des pêcheurs
de la région
à l'origine de cette pollution des
résidus des pressages de vendanges
champenoise sur près de 30 km les fortes
pluies de ces derniers jours auraient
peut-être entraîner vers la rivière ces
résidus à l'étranger l'offensive des
troupes russes en tchétchénie même si le
kremlin continue de minimiser cette
opération militaire en affirmant qu'il
ne s'agit pas d'une attaque terrestre
d'envergure
reste que trois ans après un premier
conflit qui s'était enlisé de nouveaux
combats se sont déroulés dans plusieurs
villages au nord-est de cette république
indépendante et un sentiment de déjà-vu
pour les habitants de la capitale grozny
qui n'ont ni eau ni gaz ni électricité
gilles rabin franck brisset
laon cinéma avec ralentisseur images
pour une séquence que le commentateur de
la chaîne d'état rtr qualifie lui même
de très rare exercice de propagande
destinée à rassurer l'opinion publique
qui voudrait bien croire que tous les
régiments blindés russes sont aussi
professionnel et aussi bien équipées
comme par exemple ici de blindage
explosif le top du top
leur mission n'est pas d'attaquer pas
avant deux semaines confie les officiers
mais d'établir sur une profondeur de 20
à 30 kilomètres un no man's land dans la
plaine du nord de la chine par la petite
mosquée où le président tchétchène aslan
maskhadov conduisait hier la prière du
vendredi
avec les chefs de guerre les combattants
juré de faire le jihad la guerre sainte
contre les russes un président élu mais
déclarée illégitime par la russie qui
avait pourtant si avec lui des accords
de paix ce qui n'a pas surpris les chefs
de guerre capable jordanien et bassaïev
le tchétchène avec les russes n'importe
quel accord ne vaut même pas le prix du
papier sur lequel on a signé bref cela
revient à une déclaration de guerre que
tous en russie comme en tchétchénie
savent proche désormais mais la russie
est elle en mesure d'effacer la défaite
qu'elle avait subi ici en 96
à écouter la rend d'un général à ses
soldats
oui une fois pour toutes il faut donner
une leçon à ces bandits mais à voir le
message délivré par les services de
propagande de l'état major
on peut en douter je veux dire aux amis
à ma mère et à mon père tout baigne
ne vous inquiétez pas en autriche les
élections législatives qui se
dérouleront demain est un enjeu de
taille confirmer ou non la poussée de
l'extrême droite qui a enregistré lors
des derniers scrutins régionaux des
score vertigineux ce parti xénophobe
d'après les derniers sondages contre et
27 à 28% des voix reléguant la troisième
place le parti conservateur
portrait du leader très charismatique du
fp a eu un juriste de 49 ans qui
ambitionnait ledit de devenir chancelier
olivier werner heel et jeunes bon
toujours bronzé très
et populaire il promet qu'il y aura du
changement s'il est élu chancelier
il faut le croire il dit d'abord stop à
l'immigration dans les rues de vienne à
bec new york haider on a revu des
affiches qui rappellent la propagande du
troisième reich
haider l'enfant chéri de la carinthie la
province la plus au sud du pays
élu gouverneur avec 42% des voix au
printemps dernier un électeur sur deux a
donc voté pour cet homme qui conseille
ici aux autres politiciens d'aller
visiter la banlieue de vienne avec ses
travailleurs immigrés qui empoisonnent
la vie des pauvres ce trait chien à les
voir dans les écoles aussi dit il
et tous ces enfants qui ne parlent pas
notre langue un discours qui passe bien
auprès des laissés pour compte des
protestataires de toutes sortes des
chrétiens fondamentalistes des déçus sur
les mots kratos le parti de haider un
comportement anti humanitaire les
cherche à mettre le feu le chancelier
climat chef de file à gauche qui
gouverne avec le parti conservateur
soutenu par helmut kohl durant cette
campagne formaient une coalition qui
semblait inébranlable
mais ces deux grands partis risque de
payer très cher leur immobilisme
le mouvement pour la liberté le parti de
jörg haider fondée après la guerre par
d'anciens nazis ne pesait que 5 % des
voix en 86 demain il approchera les 30%
haider a des idées que les autres n'ont
pas il a adressé un chèque de 3000
francs à toutes les mères d'enfants en
bas âge dans sa région
succès garanti forcé l'admiration des 8
millions d'autrichiens haider a utilisé
des méthodes plus ou moins dangereuses
pour se distinguer la grande bretagne
est agité par les révélations du très
sérieux journal l independence qui
affirme que l'angleterre et les états
unis connaissaient l'existence de camps
de concentration et notamment des fuites
ce dès décembre 42
c'est ce que révèle le travail
extrêmement documenté d'une
universitaire benoît duquesne c'est cet
universitaire barbara rogers qui est à
l'origine de la découverte
en faisant des recherches sur l'attitude
du gouvernement britannique pendant la
guerre et sur sa connaissance de
l'holocauste elle a trouvé ici parmi les
archives un document d'une vingtaine de
pages
c'est le compte rendu d'une réunion à la
maison blanche entre le président
roosevelt et des responsables de la
communauté juive
le 8 décembre 42 premiers documents de
ce genre qui ment
que les juifs étaient envoyés à des
juifs en bonne santé et qu'ils aient
fait exterminer dans les chambres à gaz
dès la fin de 42 les alliés savent donc
tous deux frites des chambres à gaz et
des fours crématoires ils savent que 2
millions de juifs ont déjà été
assassinés
ils savent mais ne disent rien du moins
pas en détail au parlement britannique
le ministre des affaires étrangères
annonce simplement qu hitler a engagé la
solution finale si on en avait dit plus
les anglais craignait une arrivée
massive de réfugiés de type le roman je
les lui dans un rapport officiel
mais ce n'est qu'une des raisons en fait
des 41 les alliés réussissent à
intercepter surtout à décoder les
messages allemands
c'est ainsi qu'ils apprennent en russie
l'exécution de plus de 30 mille juifs
mais le rapport restera secret pas
question pour les alliés de montrer aux
allemands qu'ils ont réussi à percer les
secrets d'énigmes à une machine d'une
incroyable complexité qui servait à
coder tous les messages des nazis
ce document retrouvé par barbara rodgers
va donc relancer la polémique sur
l'attitude des alliés en révélant
l'existence des camps d'extermination
n'aurait-il pas permis de sauver des
millions de vies pourquoi auschwitz pas
plus que les autres camps où leurs voies
d'accès n'ont ils pas été bombardé
pendant la guerre parce que ce n'était
pas une priorité militaire dit certains
historiens
parce que même en le sachant dire à
raymond aron on ne pouvait pas croire à
l'incroyable la marche et des
sans-papiers partie de tous nos il ya
plus de cinq semaines une centaine
d'entre eux sont arrivés à paris
aujourd'hui leur destination finale
après avoir parcouru un millier de
kilomètres entouré de plusieurs
centaines de personnes qui soutiennent
leurs revendications ils se sont
approchés de l'hôtel matignon vous n'en
être reçu par les neiges de ce pacte qui
n'a pas donné suite
après les déboires du parti de bruno
mégret aux dernières élections
européennes le mouvement national a
décidé de modifier son nom pour devenir
le mouvement national républicain un
nouveau baptême pour un parti qui
continue de défendre les mêmes valeurs
un tour de passe passe à la baule arnaud
boutet marie pierre cassignard
la question est simple comment rebondir
après le très mauvais résultats des
européennes alors on vote la commission
d'investiture pour les élections
municipales est plus symbolique le
changement de nom le tout jeune mn
n'existe plus il devient aujourd'hui le
mouvement national république
nous sommes sortis de l'ancien fn et 2
des erreurs le pénis maintenant nous
sommes nous mêmes et nous sommes
national et républicain république
leterme se veut rassurant et séduisant
mais le programme ne varie guère d'où ce
paradoxe le mouvement change mais veut
rester le même une changer non ou
changer de positionnement tant que vous
mettez entre le fn et le rpr
donc il ya des changements chez vous
aussi engins jeu de pantalons et des
cheminements verte la même personne
trois partis politiques chasse sur les
mêmes terres les amis de bruno mégret
savent que les prochaines batailles
seront rudes et surtout décisif
un challenge avec 3,3 leader trois
mouvements que le meilleur gagne on
espère que ce sera nous c'est pas nous
en attirant les procédures le mnr récuse
désormais la qualification d'extrême
droite
mais le discours sur l'immigration
demeure très musclé nous allons lancer
une grande campagne pour demander un
référendum sur l'immigration
nous allons dire aux français
immigration
ayons le courage de dire non parce léger
virage bruno mégret espère également
convaincre les éventuels donateurs pour
subsister
son mouvement doit rapidement collecté 2
millions de francs une condition
indispensable pour espérer tenir
jusqu'aux élections municipales cette
manifestation à bordeaux avec en tête
alain juppé le maire de la ville
accompagné de plusieurs élus socialistes
de la gironde
tous ensemble pour dénoncer les bouchons
qui encombrent bordeaux quelques 700
personnes qui demandent la construction
de nouveaux passages de la garonne à
l'origine de ses difficultés de
circulation la décision de fermer sur le
pont d'aquitaine la cinquième mois pour
éviter des accidents entre sport et
loisirs le nouvel engouement des
français pour le deux roues est le plus
traditionnel d'entre eux le vélo qui
multiplie les audaces technologique pour
attirer une nouvelle clientèle l'an
passé un million cent vingt mille vélos
sans sortie des chaînes de fabrication
française marque mise en oeuvre et mais
passionné certains vélos sont tellement
chers qu'il faut demander à voir ces
objets rares qu'on ne livre pas à la
convoitise de tous les curieux
bmw là on peut dire un bmw l'occurrence
donc ça c'est le toque tech avec fera
disque qui coûtent 30 1990 quand presque
31 me trompe à ce prix là il est plié
vous pouvez donc leur entrée dans le
corps difficile quand même de faire des
acrobaties sans craindre de casser un
vélo dont la [ __ ] coûte 800 francs et
un amortisseur arrière comme sur cet
engin uniquement réservée à la descente
6500 francs
je pense que d'ici trois ou quatre à
cinq ans on verra plus de vélo
entendez par rigide vélo sans suspension
car l'amortisseur c'est l'avenir il y en
aura bientôt sur les vélos de course
augmentant encore leurs prix vingt-trois
mille francs quand même un 3000 francs
quand même mais vous savez c'est
vraiment de la technologie au niveau de
la fabrication du cadre surtout
puisqu'on arrive à un cadre qui fait 1
kg 50
je pense que les spécialistes les
spécialistes sont ses clients sensibles
aux sirènes du marketing qui leur
propose le vélo découvert trop pour des
sommes fixés par des gens qui semble
être tombé de vélo justement pourtant
avec celui ci à 20 que 1000 francs il y
a eu rupture de stock
on n'est pas on a fait ça
essentiellement pour le circuit de la
compétition et on s'aperçoit que
finalement il ya une grosse demande
puisque la partie descente puisque cette
discipline s'appelle la descente
un engouement assez spectaculaire et si
vous n'êtes toujours pas convaincus par
le sport il y à la technologie du
confort avec ce vélo électrique 800
exemplaires vendus l'an passé pour dix
mille francs à la veille du prix de
l'arc de triomphe et les amateurs
retrouveront comme chaque année depuis
50 ans leur bible leur pari turf le
journal spécialisé des courses qui tire
à 200000 exemplaires ses lecteurs
ressemble bien évidemment aux passionnés
des champs de courses un phénomène qui
touche toutes les couches de la société
car llodra jean-françois mener
il est dans toutes les mains il trône
depuis 50 ans sur tous les champs de
courses
les turfistes les purs en analyse chaque
colonne il a probablement favorisé la
fortune de certains
il a dû en ruine et aussi beaucoup
d'autres lutteurs comme l'appellent les
passionnés c'est peut-être le seul
journal lu par toutes les couches de la
population
mais en fait on s'appuie sur lui faire
ranger
qu'il pleuve qu'il vente dès l'aube jean
pierre bailly se rend sur les pistes de
chantilly depuis 30 ans il est
journaliste correspondant du pari turf
il connaît sur le bout des sabots toute
la généalogie des grandes familles de
pur-sang son métier mais aussi sa
passion c'est de repérer les chevaux de
discuter avec les entraîneurs d'essayer
de recueillir les dernières informations
à la veille des grands prix le moindre
petit vous vos idées au courant on ne
dit pas tout non il ya des choses qui
sont qui sont des vous avez à l'heure un
cheval a souvent des petits problèmes et
on
pour le journal il ya deux grands
rendez-vous dans l'année le prix
d'amérique pour les trotteurs et l'arc
de triomphe pour le galop la parution
devant alors deux cent mille exemplaires
le 78e près d'arles de triomphe autour
du logo pour faire partie de la
rédaction il faut avoir la passion du
cheval
certains même ont la passion du jeu
demain 14 e vo son compte au départ et
les pronostics vont bon train s'arrête
mon jeu parce que c'est un choix qu
beaucoup d'atouts pour lui dans cette
course mon jeu voilà le 2 croco rouge un
outsider alors tiger hill sera
l'allemand et qui va aimer le terrain
lourd mon jeu ne le dites à personne
la coupe du monde de rugby plutôt bien
parti pour la france puisque à béziers
les tricolores ont battu le canada 33
ans va sous le regard satisfait de
jacques chirac
une victoire pas facile mais le quinze
de france a réussi à prendre le dessus
christophe du chayran frédérick basile
incontestablement le public tricolore de
béziers avait l'attend joyeuse et
décontractée
il lui même une ola d'avant match où le
président de la république leva les bras
au ciel avec un peu de retard après cinq
minutes de jeu les bleus vont inscrire
un essai en contre dans un style peu
académique mais après tout qu'importe le
stylo raphaël ibanez transmet le ballon
à garbajosa l'ailier qui va s'en
débarrasser au pied arif stéphane m'bia
qui aplatit dans l'en but
les bleus mènent 8 à 3
on les imagine rassurer mais
l'adversaire du jour est accrocheur le
demi de mêlée williams marque facilement
car la défense française ne défend pas
et le canada prend l'avantagé 10 a eu
juste avant le repos au terme d'un
contre rondement mené la france de
marquer un deuxième essai grâce à
l'athletic olivier magne troisième ligne
de tempérament et bombardier tricolore
en début de deuxième période et ce n'est
pas très flatteur pour les bleus
williams marque un deuxième essai certes
il a fait un en avant mais l'arbitré n'a
rien vu
essai transformé qui ramène le canada à
un petit point des bleus 18 à 17
il faudra attendre une pénalité en fin
de match et une combinaison avec les
gros et les petits pour que le quinze de
france prennent le large
essai collectif tout en force et un brin
de finesse de dominici qui aplatit 28 à
17 le dernier essai des bleus est le
plus beau et le plus classique
le ballon vole de mains en mains dans la
ligne d'attaqué et arrive jusqu'à emile
ntamack qui marque
voilà la france qui gagne enfin 30 3
aujourd'hui l'équipe avait la mouiller
le maillot
je pense que c'est ce qui qui est très
intéressant a là rien lâcher s est
accroché le s'est battu et avec un peu
de confiance elle deviendra un peu plus
efficace heureux public satisfaction
présidentielle et sourires des bleus le
quinze de france va mieux mais il peut
faire encore mieux
et en fin d'après midi à twickenham
premier match très réussie pour
l'angleterre qui est littéralement
écrasé l'italie 67 à 7
largement favoris les anglais en passer
huit essais y ont affligé l'italie sa
défaite la plus cuisante en cinq
confrontations
de la voile à brest le départ de
jean-luc de vente de l'aide pour un tour
du monde à l'envers le navigateur
français entreprend à tour du monde en
solitaire sans escale d'est en ouest
cent soixante jours sur la mer le
skipper originaire d'amiens était
accompagné par de nombreux curieux qui
ont suivi les derniers préparatifs cet
homme de 54 ans en est à son cinquième
tour du monde
cinéma l'acteur antonio banderas se
passe derrière la caméra c'est un
premier film il sort mercredi prochain
sur les écrans pour son coup d'essai il
met en scène le son épouse melanie
griffith dans une adaptation d'un succès
de librairie la tête dans le carton à
chapeau film loufoque de l'humour de
l'émotion parce qu'elle les champs elle
est en fuite
elle vient de tuer son mari qui l'a
frappé et l'empêchait d'aller tenter sa
chance à hollywood
voici lucile héroïne fantasque rebelles
d'un film où se mêlent la comédie et le
drame
mais la ligue du fils avait découvert le
roman bien avant de rencontrer son mari
antonio banderas lorsqu'il a décidé de
passer de l'autre côté de la caméra
cette histoire de quête de liberté s'est
imposé à lui ma femme et moi avons créé
notre société de production dans une
entrevue à l'écart du courant les
oisiens excellent film à gros budget
risque soutient que j'aime bien faire
par ailleurs quand les arrogants et vite
je n'ai rien contre ces chiffres n'ont
cherché à faire quelque chose de plus
personnel de retrouver quelque chose que
j'aurais laissé derrière moi quittant
l'espagne car nous sommes en alabama en
1965 et la cavale de lui s'il n'est
autre qu'une métaphore de la lutte de
tout un pan de la société les femmes les
noirs exclus du rêve américain antonio a
plus de sens politique
il est plus intelligent que moi c'est
sans doute parce qu'il a grandi dans
l'espagne de franco et a vécu la
libération de son pays il en a gardé un
très beau point de vue sur la liberté
les droits de l'homme et l'égalité
moi qui ai vécu en amérique
j'étais à l'abri tout ça ici qu'on n'est
pas ouvert à ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur et moi même interpellé cette
dangereuse positive être un peu de mal à
personne
le film mêle avec subtilité la grande et
la petite histoire les destins
individuels à la folie collective
bienvenue au pays tant clichés pour leur
première production pour cette première
réalisation
melanie griffith et antonio banderas
peuvent avoir le sourire ce regard
original sur l'amérique est une réussite
ou à new york une ouverture très agitée
d'une exposition jugé particulièrement
provocante au musée des beaux-arts de
brooklyn devant les portes de l'édifice
la longues files d'attentes des
visiteurs et plusieurs centaines de
catholiques descendus dans la rue ce
matin pour dire leur indignation à cette
manifestation qui montre une vierge
marie souillé par des excréments
cette controverse artistique se portent
désormais sur le plan politique
sur place notre correspondant permanent
etienne et nantes bien curieuse ambiance
en vérité ce matin devant le musée d'art
de brooklyn ou chapelet et matraques
cohabiter gentiment à l'heure où s'ouvre
et l'exposition la plus controversée de
l'année les représentantes de la
communauté catholique new yorkaise
récité des prières
il demandait à dieu de pardonner à ceux
qui osaient tourner en dérision les
images pieuses et saintes écritures et
les exposer librement dans un lieu
public
voici l'objet de la controverse
l'oeuvre d'un jeune artiste anglais la
sainte vierge de chris ofili qui a
l'étrange habitude de signer ses
peintures d'eux deux énormes excréments
d'éléphants l'oeuvre fait partie de
l'exposition cnc shon qui a déjà fait un
tabac à londres les créations de jeunes
artistes anglais création que le maire
de new york en personne s'est empressé
de tailler en pièces à jaffna ma
définition de l'art c'est que si moi je
peux le faire ce n'est pas de l'art et
ce à n'importe qui aurait pu le faire
rudolf giuliani a même tenté de faire
interdire l'exposition il est en
campagne pour les sénatoriales et
l'occasion était belle de flatter
l'électorat conservateur sa probable
adversaire madame clinton en personne a
évidemment été encouragés à se prononcer
sur la polémique
empruntant des chemins beaucoup moins
radicaux
que nous croyons soit offensé c'est une
chose de là à faire mais amusé c'est
ridicule la justice américaine a fait la
sourde oreille aux injonctions du maire
et l'exposition s'est ouverte comme
prévu de futures joutes électorales ce
face à face entre ceux qui dénient à la
création artistique le droit de tout
montrer et les farouches défenseurs de
la liberté d'expression
ce face à face donc à déjà fait au moins
un vainqueur l'exposition elle même qui
ne pouvait rêver meilleure publicité
michel legrand vient d'enregistrer à
londres son dernier album l'occasion de
renouer avec le jazz
portrait de cet artiste inclassable
pianiste chef d'orchestre compositeur le
talentueux michel le grand reportage
dominique bonnet marcel martin
on ne répète avec des potes trois notes
de jazz et l'on saisit immédiatement le
personnage mais pas vraiment le style la
merveille de certaines parties musicales
c'est que ça ne s'explique pas la
musique ça s'écoute ça c'est ça ça on
est sensibles on en tremble on ne veut
dire on a à ses émotions mais on ne les
explique pas vous dire voilà savait
alors moi j'ai un truc formidable
voilà ma couture non je sais pas bref le
style le grand est insaisissable qu'il
soit à paris à los angeles à tokyo ici à
londres
ce musicien est tout à la fois pianiste
chanteur compositeur arrangeur et chef
d'orchestre pas toujours facile pas
facile en ce sens je suis très exigeante
à dire que quand je fais alors qu'istres
le fait on peut enfin en fonctionnement
avec des gens avec lesquels on doit
faire la même chose
salut si les mains seraient désastreuses
du studio du 10
je veux que ce sera magnifique
l'émotion d'un souvenir celui de son ami
miles davis et michel legrand revient au
jazz avec son coeur comme à 26 ans
lorsqu'il dirigeait déjà john coltrane
ou bill evans ou comme lorsqu'il
écrivait ses musiques de films auxquels
les angles des rentes hommage
beaucoup
et nous sommes deux soeurs
mais si tu tiens t'es chez moi mais
pactole admirer la vue
michel legrand écrit ainsi plus de 150
musiques de films obtenu trois oscars et
pourtant après 49 ans de carrière on
n'arrive toujours pas à savoir quel est
son style
reportage donc signé frédéric bonnet et
marcel martin savane ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres
l'offensive des troupes russes en
tchétchénie de violents combats dans des
villages du nord-est de cette république
du caucase opération militaire avec la
poursuite des bombardements
la coupe du monde de rugby un bon départ
pour les tricolores qui ont battu à
baiser cet après-midi le canada 33 20
sous le regard de jacques chirac dans un
instant la météo nathalie rihouet 20h55
au fil du temps présenté par gérard
holtz avec zinedine zidane comme vous ne
l'avez jamais entendue entouré des mais
jacquet des tricolores un rendez vous à
ne pas manquer 1h10 le dernier journal
florence duprat de master dans thé ou
café
catherine ne sait la crds soit la
chanteuse lio à midi des m à l'émission
de paul amar j'aurai le plaisir de vous
retrouver demain dès 13 heures je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2
autre